-Today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and, of course, send out
thank-you notes.
And I was just --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running a bit behind
today, so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that cool with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
Little extra flair there,
I heard that.
[ Imitates a cat purring ]
[ Notes play ]
Yeah, yeah.
You put a little extra.
-Put a little English on it.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
It's the holidays.
-Yeah a little sprinkle, man.
[ Clears throat ]
Thank you, "House of Gucci"
or as I like to call you
Italian succession.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
-It's good.
-What's a matter for you?
-Thank you, 75% of Americans,
limiting the relatives
they invite to Thanksgiving
because of COVID
or as 100% of them put it,
"Yeah, we're not inviting
them because of COVID."
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
Are you vaccine?
Yeah. Oh, we don't want anybody
who's vaccine.
Did you get your booster?
-We're celebrating the 26th.
-The 26th we're gonna be there.
You know, where Walmart is?
We'll be celebrating
that parking lot.
We'll meet you there,
don't worry about it.
-You're going to celebrate
Thanksgiving in Walmart?
-Yeah.
-Noice! [Nice]
Noice! That's righteous.
-Thank you, Adele's "30," for
being the official soundtrack
of staring out a window with
your hand against the glass.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Vocalizes ]
-It's out.
Thank you, booster shots,
to be a good thing for society,
but sounding like a tequila,
you give to toddlers.
[ Laughter ]
-For teething. For teething.
-Thank you, calling someone
on their birthday,
for being 10 seconds
of excitement,
followed by 10 minutes
of awkwardness.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Happy birthday.
-Uh, did they already sing?
Thank you,
moving walkways at airports,
for being the best way
of getting to my gate
exactly 14 seconds faster.
[ Laughter, Applause ]
Thank you,
KitchenAid stand mixer,
for making sure I can't make
baked goods until I can deadlift
all 400 pounds of you
onto my counter.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Grunts ]
[ Imitates crash ]
-Gosh.
-Oh, where's the blades?
-Is that the last one?
-What was that?
-That's the last.
-Yes.
-Thank-you note,
Tariq's gonna be here for,
like, a month or two.
-Yeah, that's right.
I'm going to miss Tariq, man.
I'm going to miss you, bud.
-I'm going to miss you, too,
man.
-I mean, [muffled chanting]
Speech.
-From me?
[ Audience starts chanting
"Speech" ]
-I mean, you know, listen.
-They want one.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
You know, at the top of,
of one mountain
represents the bottom
of of the next.
-Oh, my goodness never mind.
-Wow!
-Boo! Boo! [ Laughs ]
-I really, you know.
[ Laughs ]
-Your high school yearbook quote
or something? No.
-Too good.
-It's too good.
-To be.
Wait a minute.
Is this really the last one?
-Yeah.
-Oh, well, I didn't know.
-Thank you, cornucopias
for being baskets
that are bad at their job.
There you have it, everybody,
those are "Thank You Notes!"